[Music]
how did your brother scare you just
i mean he would like come at me like
across the room and like get in my face
but when we were younger um he would
like literally push us down and like get
in our face and like pin us down
and like wouldn't let us go
[Music]
yo yo yo what up this is john with the
dr john dolone show welcome welcome
we're so glad you're here
welcome
hey if you are
in a bad mood have we got the show for
you
i just said that i don't even know
what's coming in this show so
if you're in a bad mood
this actually might not be the show for
you it might though here's what's cool
about it you're gonna find out at the
end whether you shouldn't have listened
to it or you should have that's the cool
thing that's what we do here on the show
if you want to be on it go to uh go to
johndaloney.com
ask ask or give me a shout at
1-844-693-3291
um after this incredible show intro
you can see what just high quality this
thing is uh if you will make sure you
subscribe on the tubes or to podcasts
that would be awesome
um one quick funny thing so right after
this show i'm gonna as soon as the
show's over i'm gonna sprint into the
next studio over here and do a
national media hit and it's a
pretty long interview on
basically the biology of women's stress
and the way the pandemic has affected
women's particularly in the elevated
stress that women are experiencing and
this morning
i was telling my wife i was like hey
i've got to do a long interview today
about women's stress
and she just sat down on the chair and
looked at me and goes hmm really
tell me more
man
mail
and so she was right so i thought that
was a good reminder to everybody
sometimes i answer questions on the show
it's kind of ridiculous that i'm
answering these shows right i don't have
lived experience in all of these things
and so i always want to point back to
experts when i can i always want to
point back to the science when i can and
most importantly the reason i love the
show
is that it's real people telling their
real stories and the real experiences
that they're having in their lives and
so always remember
man i went to a lot of school but i'm
still figuring this out too
and i love walking alongside people i do
and tonight you can rest assured i will
not be talking to my wife about what i
know about women's stress i'll be asking
her how are you well i'm doing the
dishes and vacuuming at the same time
let's go to tyler in dallas what's up
tyler
hi can you hear me i can what's up
okay
um uh
so i don't i don't know where to start
um just anywhere is cool we can make it
up as we go
okay okay um i have come i guess to the
conclusion
that my parents were very
emotional and mature
i think is the word
and um
it was really hard
and uh like growing up
and i had a older brother who
like really scared me a lot
and um
and i just didn't
know what to do
and um
uh
i
as a 15 year old you know what else do
you do
um i say that kind of like as a joke um
how did your brother scare you um just
like
really aggressively it wasn't anything
like like sexual or anything but just
i mean he would like come at me like
across the room and like get in my face
and um did he ever hit you
uh not so much like by the time i was 15
but when we were younger um he would
like literally push us down and like get
in our face and like pin us down
and like wouldn't let us go
and
and um
you said us did you have other siblings
in the house yeah i had i have two older
brothers
and a younger sister and um
i like i would i would like lay awake
and like
be scared
and i don't know sometimes i just wish
my sister was a little bit more vocal
than i was and
i was scared for her and i would just
think like just hush like you don't know
what he's going to do yeah and um
anyway i'm sorry
no don't hold on never apologize okay
i'm so sorry that happened
your older brother is supposed to be
your pathway through life right
supposed to clear the deck for his baby
sister
supposed to
supposed to hold her up hold on hold on
hold on
your brother should have given you some
things that he didn't give you and i'm
so sorry
and your parents should not have let
that nonsense go on and i'm so sorry
um thank you and um
i don't i've never actually said like
things like that out loud
um
anyway so
i'm just by myself a lot because i just
don't want to be around people and
you know your mind
can
take advantage of you sometimes and i uh
i
started like self-harming i guess yeah
maybe is the term to use i don't know
that's that's all that's all like that's
like all clinically uh
uh
tell me about what actually happens in
practice
um
i guess maybe like cutting myself yeah
um
and
anyway it was never for like
like suicidal reasons it was just
i don't know how i got to that point i
don't know how i
i don't know
what made me think that was
a good thing to do i don't know
um
anyway so
that's kind of the premise of
my recent
problems um
i had my and i did that all through high
school and then after high school it got
a lot better um my brother did
eventually
um move out and eventually stop coming
back
and
so that helped a lot and i met my
husband and that helped a lot a lot
and
um
so i thought i was getting better i
thought i was
getting better
and um
anyway
two years ago i had
my second son
and
around three to four months i noticed
there was just something different
and
um i couldn't handle it i just couldn't
handle it and
um
i
i just sort of like started
i guess cutting myself again and
i
i didn't know what to do and
over time i think i've i've gotten a
little better
and
but now i worry that like what if it
comes back and
you know i have kids now and
i just i don't know what to do and i
want to
talk to someone that
i don't know like necessarily what to
say and
i don't know i i'm worried that
like
i'm worried that
if i start talking to
like let's say a professional
does that mean i have to kind of like
tell everyone else and because i don't i
don't want to tell everyone else i don't
know if that's
like the wrong way to look at it but i
don't want anyone to know and
my husband does
know as far as
um before we met
and
but he i don't i don't think he knows
like recently
and
unless he just doesn't want to say i
don't know um
and i don't want to i don't want him to
start worrying about me
i don't know i don't know what to do so
number one tyler i wanna
this is
some of the bravest five minutes that
has ever taken place on this show
okay
okay
in your heart
silence keeps you safe
disappearing keeps you safe
and it has your whole life
and at the same time our bodies will
scream at us from the inside out
help help help help help right
and you've learned you watched your
sister who talked a lot she got it worse
than you did
and you learned silence
and that thing that kept you alive
is now slowly burying you right
and so
before we start walking into some of
this i need you to hear me say loudly
when you tell me that you're cutting
that doesn't even make my eyes browse go
up
you're not broken you're not screwed up
you're not messed up
you're not dysfunctional you're not less
than okay
and if you've listened to this show
people tell me things and i go whoa oh
my goodness it i'm not doing that with
this
okay
okay
um
i can tell that this is a coping
strategy you don't want to use anymore
and i applaud that and i think there's
some way better coping strategies but
given what you've experienced and i bet
you and i could sit down for a couple
hours over some nachos and you could
tell me some stories that would make my
eyebrows go through the top of my
forehead is that probably true
is that is that honestly true
um yeah
just things like that my parents used to
say that's right and that your brother's
picking up sometimes yeah there you go
and so
the first thing we do me a huge favor i
want you to take as deep a breath as you
possibly can hold it all the way in and
breathe it all the way in and hold it
ready go
hold it
and let it out
and right now i bet your shoulders are
two inches from your ears i want you
just to drop them down
okay
saying
you're hurt out loud is one of the
single bravest things you can do and you
just did it
and i'm so proud of you i'm glad to call
you my friend okay
okay
um
so
cutting is i'll do a whole show on it
one day we'll do a whole segment on it
one day okay that's not for today but
we'll do that one day i'll kind of walk
through it all
ultimately over the last 20 years i've
worked with so many young people usually
women um young women who are who are
dealing with stressors that that exceed
their body's ability to help themselves
okay it's when like this cup only holds
this much water and the pipe bursts
above it
and i uh i've been really inspired by dr
anna lemke's work about dopamine and how
the pain pleasure balance works and all
that but
most of the time over the last 20 years
the words i've heard repeatedly are
something along the lines of
i just had to feel something
i needed a release
it doesn't even hurt it just makes
everything feel a little bit better
do any one of those three words apply to
your your situation
yeah i would definitely say it was just
it was
i don't know it seems simple
there's don't minimize it
which one of the ones that made the most
sense to you just then
um
maybe just head
maybe the last one
you may have to repeat it
just just that um
everything builds up inside so much and
it doesn't even hurt as much as
i can see it
i can see the
the bits of blood i can see it i can
feel it and then shortly thereafter
yes definitely like how your voice is
right now after taking one deep breath
and dropping your shoulders
it's it's that right
our bodies release our own opioids when
we're hurt
and sometimes there's there's a hack
to it's it's not an all the way opi it's
not like taking you know oxys or
something but there is a path that way
that sometimes just goes
okay
i want you to know as a little girl
who had a
repeated
trauma with her big brother you had a
bear that your body was trying to run
from except he lived in the next room
over
yeah
that you have a little cup underneath
the pipe that had burst and it just
overflowed and so as a high school kid
i'm so sorry that you had to deal with
that by yourself
you're not screwed up from cutting
where you end up getting yourself well
i've seen people get themselves into
trouble let me say it that way with
cutting is the shame that follows
and it's everything is about secrecy
everything is about i just have this
i've got this tool i've got this hack
that lets me get to the next minute into
the next minute into the next minute
and as i've heard you say it i don't
want anyone to if i tell a therapist i
have to tell everybody i didn't want my
husband to know that's the language of
shame
that's the language of somewhere deep
inside is a little girl asking herself
why wouldn't my parents just freaking
protect me
and they didn't
why didn't my older brother be the
normal older brother
and beat up my boyfriends and make jokes
but also i knew i was a princess around
him
why didn't i get that older brother
right
does that sound right
yes
i i used to look at my friends and like
had like when their siblings and i don't
know how they had that
so
here is the
here is the
i want to take cutting and put over to
the side for a second because as far as
i'm concerned right now cutting's not
the problem cutting's the solution okay
so when you feel that urge
and also it's super common with um
post-pregnancy okay
postpartum cutting is super common too
there's that sense of like i don't know
what are we what are we doing what are
we doing and it just builds and builds
and builds and builds right going back
to i've got that little cup and it's
overflowing so let's put cutting over to
the side here okay that's not the
problem
the problem
again this is you and i talking for just
a few minutes here but the big neon sign
that i want to start with
is
what kept you alive is now hurting you
okay the same thing that kept you alive
is not hurting you and that's silence
the greatest gift you can give your body
your husband your children
you is to begin to tell your story
it's to
as the great rene brown says shame eats
secrets for breakfast and so what we're
going to do is we're going to start to
lean into and a secret free life
and here's what that will do it will be
the most exposing it will be like
running down the street naked in a
parade
okay
you've never done it you've never had to
do it and it's going to be a skill that
you're going to have to learn and
practice
and it's going to come in fits and
starts and rages and tears and yelling
and hiding it's going to come all that
stuff to expect it
the same as you went and had surgery and
you have to go through rehab that's
where we're at now we're going to learn
how to tell what happened
and we're going to do that with a
therapist who knows what they're talking
about and when you go see a counselor
you have to tell nobody
and if the counselor tells somebody
they're breaking the law
okay
and their license gets taken away
but this story's got to be told just
feel how your body feels right now after
saying it once for the first time
yeah and when you find yourself in a
position where you feel like cutting
you're going to develop and it's not
going to take you super long
you're going to develop a language with
your husband where you say hey i'm
feeling really stressed right now
and that's not you being a wimp that's
not you
uh running and hiding that's you
understanding that your voice matters
that your your role and your
relationship matters that you matter
and that right now i'm starting to
things are piling up on me
sure we all know that seven miles down
the road what that could end up at that
could end up as me cutting again that
could end up as me having too many
drinks or in my house that could end up
with me and four cartons of ice cream in
the middle of the front yard and i'm not
wearing a shirt i'm just sitting in a
bathing suit like a weirdo right it can
we all know where that could go those
are all solutions the problems are back
here
does that sound
reasonable
yeah
i'm nervous you're gonna get off the
phone you're gonna feel better for about
five minutes and you're not gonna say
anything
i don't know what to say
would you call a counselor today in your
area and tell them i'm not okay
yeah i can
do you promise that you'll do that
i i promise
if you my dad
he was a homicide detective for a long
time but then he became a minister for a
short season for a while for several
years and so since my dad's a minister
if you lie to me it's all you'll get
struck by lightning or something like
that
[Music]
that's not really true i just made that
up
no do you promise she'll make that call
i will i will here's the second here's
the second conversation
i want you to bring your husband on
board
okay will you tell him that you're not
okay
uh i will
i may let him listen to this
call maybe
it won't come out for like a month
oh yeah yeah you're right here
[Laughter]
nice try tyler i know i know
okay how about this okay well they're
gonna clip it and they're gonna send it
to you is that cool
okay yeah that's great here's what i
heard when you just mentioned your
husband he's an incredible guy isn't he
he is
like of all of the men who failed you
before your brothers your dad he stepped
up huh
okay
it's gonna be hard to reach out across
that and trust and i think he's earned
that according to you right he's earned
that trust
and yeah
so i want you to do it while holding his
hands okay
okay so here's how the conversation goes
i talked to this podcaster today and
your husband's gonna go what i thought
you weren't like
i know i know i know i made a call and
then we held him and then you want you
to hold his hands and say i've got some
hard things i got to tell you
starting with i'm not okay
starting with um
the stress is built up and i've got some
stuff that i've got to deal with from
all the way back to when i was a little
girl but it's paying off right now i've
started cutting again
i'm stressed and i'm struggling um and
i'm going to reach out to a counselor
and i want you to walk alongside me in
this
i want you just to say it just like that
okay okay
and he sounds like a man who will
grab you in his arms and hold you tight
and say i love you
i'm not gonna try to solve you i'm not
gonna try to give you advice i love you
and then we're going to start from there
is that cool
yeah is that the kind of guy he is
yeah he's the best
it's so good
so good can i tell you
i don't come face to face
nose to nose eye to eye with bravery
very often and i did today
and you and i could see like i said we
could spin this is just scratching the
surface of this call and i know that
sweetie and i know that you and i could
talk for a long time about cutting and
about trauma and about your brother's
abuse and about your parents dysfunction
i know all that stuff but right now
everything is you looking in the mirror
and saying
i got two little babies i got a great
husband and most importantly i got me
and i'm worth this conversation
i'm worth calling and getting help i'm
worth not carrying this stuff around i'm
not carrying my parents crap anymore i'm
not here my brother's crap anymore
i'm changing this family tree and it
starts today
so so grateful for you tyler bravery
bravery we'll be right back
[Music]
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to jacob
in saint louis what's up jacob
not much doctor john how about you
man we're getting there man we're
getting there what's up
i just got a question for you um i was
wondering your thoughts on how much
detail of my trauma i should share with
my wife
oh that's a great question tell me more
um i
so i've been through
through a bit um lots and lots of
childhood trauma
so
i'm
she knows that some stuff has happened
we just haven't gone into a whole lot of
detail on some things
you know she knows she's seen some of my
scars you know things like that
um so
sorry ah dude you're good brother so
i just i
i've got a therapist that i go to i've
got a really good group of guys around
me
i i just i don't want to
add too much onto her and i know that
marriage is we're walking through life
together somewhat
i just don't know where that line is
because i don't want to lay her down too
much that's man your heart's so good man
and good for you for doing the hard hard
work of getting a counselor getting a
group of people around you that's
awesome good for you man
um
so
you know this and so i'm gonna talk to
the audience and
i'm gonna talk to you like we're having
a conversation but really i'm talking to
a broader audience for about 30 seconds
is that cool totally yeah absolutely
you know the difference between
discussion of general trauma and gory
details right
yeah there's a difference between saying
hey that guy hit me
and
that guy beat the crap out of me
and
that guy ripped chunks of flesh out with
a board
because it had a nail in it he wouldn't
stop hitting me that one time and then
he made me get dressed and go to church
right you see the difference in those
three stories
yeah yeah
and
what i've found in my own personal life
dealing with my own trauma and walking
alongside folks is
there's this
i want to be known
and i want to be fully known
and i want to be fully loved
i want both of those things i think
that's the core human need right is to
be known and loved
and
once i can let somebody know and say hey
i was abused
and they'll go man i'm so sorry and then
i want to be like yeah but you don't
fully know hold on right and the
temptation is to keep going and going
and going and then here's the other
temptation for most people who were
abused had some sort of trauma
who then
go on a healing journey
we become protectors
am i right
yeah yeah that's
absolutely me we look out for the others
that becomes our life's work i'm on a
podcast right now right i mean it's like
help this is what we become this is who
we become we help other people whether
we're accountants and we noticed that
woman at the coffee machine her head's
hanging a little low
we just become highly attuned to other
people's hurt why because it kept us
alive
kept us safe right
so here's what i'm going to challenge
you to do and this is hard
actually before i challenge you with my
challenge i'm gonna write my challenge
down here
why now why is this come up
um it's
i i stuffed it for a while and it's been
four years of therapy
and i just recently got married actually
so uh five weeks tomorrow um
so that's probably part of it yeah
or as they say all of it that could be a
lot of women
um is any of your trauma family in
origin
um tell me some high level yeah as much
as you're comfortable with
high level um i was abused
sexually in some ways by my mother and
father okay physically abused father
stepfather mother okay um a couple
elementary school teachers as well okay
um
that's the super high level but mostly
family of origin yeah so
your brain's got us got a it's put a pin
right it's put a a gps pin and a couple
of narratives
husband and wife not safe
teachers not safe uncle's not safe right
you see where i'm going or men in power
over me not safe
yeah what do you do for a living right
now
um i'm a program manager um in a
training department
so i make sure everybody gets trained
there you go
you make sure everybody gosh the trauma
just keeps replaying itself
or the the roots the the rings that my
dad just said like you throw a brick
into a lake and the rings just go right
and people who have been experienced
trauma who then go on to become helpers
it's just it's almost like a script
sometimes
um
so you get married you bring somebody
really really close to you your body's
gonna sound the alarms that hey we
remember this jacob not good not good
right yeah yep and you also have done
enough work
and you're an extra godly i wish i could
connect you with the previous caller man
because she was brave as all get out
you're brave as i'll get out and you're
just her down the down the road a bit
um because she's starting her bravery
journey now
um yeah that's not true she's been on a
brave journey forever she's starting her
the healing process in a new way i'm
proud of her i just wanted to yell
through the phone you know i know i know
me too i just want to yeah it's so good
man but hey she'll hear the chorus of
people who love her too and you will
also
um
so you've done enough of your work to
know the only way
to have a good marriage the only way for
you to continue to heal is to actually
get closer to the relationship at the
same time your body is going what are
you doing right yeah exactly and
you're gonna try to protect your wife
and so here's the challenge for you okay
okay
is to let her be an adult
and this is what i mean by that
how old is she
she's a year older than me she's 29.
okay all right so she's seen life too
it's not like you're 19 and she's 18
right yeah um
and i know internets i'm an aegis when
it comes to some of the stuff just
everybody shake it off so she's 29 year
28
this is where you invite her in
invite her to a counseling session or
you let her know
i think at some point in our
relationship i'm going to want to tell
you
some of the depths
of the things i've experienced
but i also want to respect your
boundaries of what you want to hear what
you can hear
what you're interested in hearing
and
let her
own her own autonomy
okay
all right and you're gonna have to
dial back the protector impulse you have
which you've developed honestly and good
over the last 20 years 30 years
and also
you're going to at the you're going to
be co-creating a new relationship that
you've never experienced before which is
where both people say their needs out
loud and both people work to help the
other person meet their needs
you see how what we're doing here
yeah yeah i do
so
don't protect her and don't bomb her
either invite her into the conversation
and also say if you don't want to hear
the gory details and you mean you may
want to use more sophisticated eloquent
language than that
my wife tells me that sometimes i'm his
i'm his uh
i'm a little bit obtuse when i just put
things out there and i could probably be
a little more sensitive um
if she wants to hear hear some of the
details you would love to
you would love to tell her someday you'd
love to invite her into that
conversation when she's ready if she's
ready
um and
you may want to do that with your
counselor the first time
because that's been a safe place for you
to do your trauma work right
yeah and she's part of the reason i
marry her is uh she actually started
going to counseling with me um before i
even proposed so oh there you go so you
all have a routine already right we do
we do okay and so maybe in your next
counseling session does she still go
with you
yeah yeah we we alternate so um one week
one of us and then the other week we'll
go together
cool dude your marriage
you realize dude you have changed your
family tree
you did jacob jacob no no not going you
did
and
most people at the walmart or wherever
aren't gonna see underneath your flannel
shirt that you're wearing and see all
those scars and the burn marks
and the scars they're not gonna see it
but your grandkids that haven't been
born yet will be a beneficiary because
you turn and stare down that forest fire
like i do i don't want you to miss that
because the four years every other week
it turns into this and i'm going to work
and i'm making sure billy hasn't turned
his programming thing in and the tps
reports and the cover sheets
i need you to hear me say the work you
have done is generational and i'm proud
of you
and it sucks didn't it
yeah yeah
the way you said that's awesome yeah
yeah yeah i did john thanks for bringing
that up idiot yes it's so hard
i'm so so proud of you
i'm i this couldn't i mean there
couldn't be a better call on planet
earth i'm so grateful that these things
lined up this way
um
jenna mann's is kelly yolk so great that
tyler entering into the story and you at
the transition phase man so beautiful so
beautiful i'm proud of you my brother
invite her into that conversation you
guys are weight on the road i'd bring it
up at the next counseling session and
just say hey i would like to invite you
into some deeper details here and i want
to give you permission to say i don't
want to be a part of those things i love
you and i don't need to know those
things
or i am interested in knowing those
things deeper and give her permission
and don't hate her either way don't get
upset either way it's not personal it's
her stating her boundaries and her needs
which are awesome and they'll shift over
time too one way or the other
ah so so incredible i'm gonna give you a
copy of
own your past change your future i'm
gonna send you two actually one for you
and one for your wife and when y'all get
done with them you can give one to a
friend of yours who's working through a
similar thing
a lot of folks who have made the turn
you've made dealing with severe
childhood trauma
who have gone on to be a helper and done
their own work
other people who've been traumatized
just find them just the way the world
works man and you'll be able to hand
this book so i'm going to send you two
copies of this thank you so much for
being awesome and uh kelly let's send
one to tyler too um that'd be awesome
also all right hey everybody we'll be
right back
hey john delony here i say it all the
time there are no tips or tricks or
hacks when it comes to living a better
life it all comes down to being
intentional with the practices you do
every day and the most important
practice you can do to improve your
mental and physical health is to start
getting enough quality sleep i know this
from personal experience and from the
data and for me good sleep starts with a
world-class mattress it's why my family
sleeps on dream cloud mattresses whether
you're a back sleeper a stomach sleeper
an edge of the bed sleeper or just a
weird sleeper right or you have to make
room for your dog dream cloud's combo of
gel memory foam and coil technology
keeps you comfortable all night and
dream cloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for our listeners
499 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of
dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protector luxury sheets
all of it it's time to change your sleep
and change your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new savings and your
new mattress today
all right we are back let's go to
jennifer in ann arbor michigan what's up
jennifer
how much how are you good are you a huge
ohio state fan
uh no
[Laughter]
uh no
in fact i'm hanging up
how are you
i'm okay i'm okay just dealing with um
some family issues aren't we all right
like what you got what you got
so
um at the end of september my mom died
oh can we just park there for a second
what was her name
uh catherine
oh how she had she had she passed away
she um actually had als but we didn't
find that out until the january january
of that year so okay she passed about 10
months uh yeah almost 10 months after we
found out i'm so sorry
that's okay
she'd been dealing with something we
couldn't that nobody could figure it out
for a couple of years
um so it was good that she passed
quickly because she was basically
bedridden
that's so hard that's so hard on
everybody man
yeah oh so then the family showed up
then what happened
um well that all went okay but um
two weeks ago my dad called and dropped
a bomb on me
and the bomb is that he's getting
remarried he's gonna say he's getting
married oh my gosh
to
who somebody from church that he's only
known for about three months oh man um
and you know that
my dad was the
youngest child
of six
and when he moved out from his parents
he moved in with my uncle and then he
met my mom and married my mom and moved
in with my mom so he's never lived alone
and had to take care of himself okay
so i understand that he's really
lonely and probably hungry too
but the thing that bothered me i wasn't
even really upset that he was
going to move on i wasn't even really
upset about that how old is he about
he's um he'll be 72 this year okay all
right
um what i'm upset about though is that
he
didn't even give like one
second thought about
me
in this whole process and i'm his only
child i have a half brother but he's my
mom's son
um
you know like he never told me he was
dating anybody he never told me that he
was spending time with anyone
and i would you know i called him weekly
because he knew i knew he was lonely he
only had the dog and the tv for company
yeah um
you know
it was like he didn't
he didn't want me there yeah
um can i reframe it for you
sure i just uh i just i just
talked to somebody recently um very
similar experience very similar age
and
the word um
and they've started talking to somebody
and
the word that kept coming up over and
over was guilt
guilt guilt guilt guilt
and i'm imagining a scenario right i'm
making this up
so there's two stories here one is your
dad's a jerk he's cutting his daughter
out he's like screw you i only got 20
years left i'm gonna ride to the wheels
fall off and you're not a part of it
that could be story one okay
story two could be
i wanna give my daughter as much time as
possible to grieve her mama
and the picture of our family
and the good stuff and the bad stuff and
the messy stuff i don't want to break
her heart
but god i'm lonely too
and then miss thang just walks in here
to the church and then it's all right
and then that happens
and then celine dion starts playing and
the whole thing just here we go so yeah
i think there's really two ways you can
move forward
one way is you can sit down and tell
your dad hey dad i just need you to know
this hurt my feelings
yeah
um
you don't even know um the rest of this
oh okay bring it bring it
so i i i did talk to my dad and you know
he said he was sorry for hurting me i'm
like you're not hurting me that you want
to get married you're hurting me that
you're excluding me from it okay so hold
on can we just stop it god this is like
the show of bravery good for you
you expressed your feelings to your dad
man
what a rock star this [ __ ] this is like
the this is like good i'm gonna put all
three of y'all's faces on the cover of
the show i won't actually do that but
wow so i i rarely talk they're like what
i can tell my dad how i feel good for
you and then it went sideways so what
happened
it did go sideways so he
he said
um
well well
because my my knee we're already coming
down to texas for my niece's wedding
in about two months she's getting
married at the end of may
and i said can't you know can't you wait
until we're down there in may like you
know two of my boys are going to be able
to come
and
chris my husband and i will be down
there and
is could we wait so that we could all be
together and do this
and he said well i'll talk to her and
then she actually messaged me on
facebook and said they were going to
wait but then
my mom's
best friend called me and said your dad
just came over here and invited us to
the wedding and it's april 2nd so
they're not waiting
did you call your dad back my dad had
not called me and told me that they
decided not to wait did you call him
back
no i haven't
i haven't i just did all of this
praising about how brave you were and i
take it all back all of it
i just wasn't i wasn't sure
i i wasn't i don't know i kind of feel
like it's his responsibility as my dad
to call me and say hey
i know we told you we're gonna wait but
we're not gonna wait and you know you
can stream the wedding from the church
and and here's what they were doing at
what time we're doing it but he hasn't
done that and so i just i don't know i
didn't know if i should call him and
call him out or
i i if
based on what you've told me about your
relationship with him so far i would
because i i'm not
especially like a message from somebody
else from somebody else on facebook i'm
not going to let that affect my
physiology and biology until i can just
talk to the real person
yeah and so
i'm just gonna
yeah
i would be on the phone just like did
you move your wedding up to april 2nd or
i just got a message from a message that
you moved your wedding up to april 2nd
is that accurate
and
part of me and my guts thinks that you
know that's probably actually what's
happening
is that what you think oh yeah my my
half brother told me yeah that dad
texted me and invited me to the wedding
and it's on april 2nd
hmm
like so all of all the stuff i said
earlier if you're listening to this show
and it applies to you great
jennifer i'm just gonna say i'm sorry
that sucks
it does like your dad kind of host you
i'm sorry
yeah
i wish it wasn't like that and there's
part of you that feels like you're it's
not it's not
it feels like you lost two parents
that's yeah it's hard
yeah i feel like you know she's got
three daughters they all live down there
he's got a new family and it's
we're moving forward and
you know you're part of the past so yeah
i mean i don't really think that he
feels like that but that's kind of how
it's making me feel
1 000
and it's hard when you've expressed your
feelings and the person in front of you
says i hear you thank you so much then
they go do exactly opposite or they're
dishonest with you right it's brutal man
that gets in your soul right
ugh i'm sorry that happened
so yeah i wish i had another nicer
weight like your dad's just hosing you
he's not be he's allowed to do whatever
he wants to do
he's he's not being a person of
character he's not being a person of
integrity he's not respecting his
daughter and i'm sorry because you
deserve all three of those things
your dad's integrity your dad's respect
and um
i i hate that for you man
so
ultimately
when it all distills down
you can't do a single thing about him
his actions his thoughts his
love for this woman none of that
right all you can deal with is you so my
question for you is what's next what are
you gonna do
oh
that's why i haven't called him because
i i just wasn't sure how i wanted to
handle it okay that sounds like the two
paths forward are to get in touch with
them and say hey did you move your thing
to april 2nd
and not in a mean and not in an
exasperated way just a factual facts of
your friends like hey did you move this
to april 2nd
um
and you know what you could do you could
send flowers expect we can't make it on
that day and we'd already told joey and
send flowers and we wish you all the
best
and in four months when this thing's off
the rails being weird and he calls you
then you can make that choice then
um
the other thing you can do is go to war
and i just
you got a guy who's broken and grieving
and war is not he's just gonna end up in
piles of bodies why you know what i mean
yeah yeah i do um
i don't think your dad's moving on from
you forever i think your dad is found a
tiny flashlight in a giant pit of
despair
and
it's a something that he just keeps
staring directly into the middle of
and i think that will resurface in a few
months maybe i'm nuts
maybe your dad hasn't liked you ever and
this is his moment to finally escape
jennifer finally and he's going to be on
the front row with his face painted in
ohio state garb
maybe that's the case
um and he's been in your michigan family
forever
my guess is probably not
but i will say this just as your friend
i'm sorry you deserve better than that
thank you
i wish there was another thing i wish i
could give you like another thing that
just kind of is what it is
oh yeah that's what my husband says too
and hey let's be super on is there
anything worse than when your husband's
like right
oh it's the worst
my husband's always right
somebody finally said it somebody
finally said it well jennifer i'm so
grateful for you um thanks for calling
and walking us through and letting me
throw all my thesis these thesises these
i don't know how to say that all of my
uh
thoughts against a wall but yeah man
that's just hard i'm sorry being left
out of the new wedding and the new life
and the new all of this
so so hard
if i'm you i'd call them that's the best
i can say i'd call them say hey did you
move to april 2nd and then i'm going to
send flowers and then i'm going to move
on and i hate that hate that hate that
kid is your dad
we'll be right back
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything
i've met with law enforcement military
folks struggling single moms company
presidents and everybody in between and
there is one thread that weaves through
all of these different people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
we'll walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
so go to
to take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back hey let's take a
breather those calls man calls on
today's show were heavy these were heavy
and there's some excitement and there is
some deep deep hurt and trepidation and
there was also
some just
like they left me right this has been a
heavy show i want to pivot a little bit
and just do a quick man i talk about
this so much i've got a partnership with
a mattress company i am i tell everybody
on planet earth 10 times over they need
to be listening to podcasts with dr
matthew walker on them
um who's one of the sleep gurus
um
in my new book on your past change your
future and i just anytime somebody hears
the phrase in my new book they're like
all right i'm done with the podcast hang
with me hang with me
one of the important things we talk
about is this idea that
we've become smarter than sleep
i'm obsessed with it yes but we've
become smarter than sleep
sleep was a thing that we had to do
until we came up with better things
in the 40s americans slept eight hours
per night in the 1940s and
our average today is about six and a
half hours in less than a century we've
lost almost 20 15 20 of our sleep we
just lopped it off and on most nights 40
percent of people in the us one out of
two are sleeping less than six hours a
night
please hear me say this that is
catastrophic
you can go to all the counseling you can
eat all the keto diets or be fully vegan
you can have all the deep tissue
massages and
yolos and treat yourselves you want
if your body isn't getting the
restorative sleep it needs none of that
matters
it just doesn't matter it's like you can
build the coolest biggest awesomest
house with solar panels and out of
concrete and steel and lasers and
whatever and if you build it
on a poor foundation the whole thing
falls down all of it
somewhere between the 1940s in the start
of
time the dawn of time
and between the 1940s and today
with all the lights and screens and
events
we used to not be able to go to roman
coliseums at nine o'clock at night
because there was no light
they had to do that stuff during the day
go back and watch those cool old movies
they all the the cool sporting events
were in the middle of the day because
there was no lighting rigs right we have
24-hour news cycles all these things
sleep has now become something that's in
the way
it's in the way of our productivity it's
in the way of our entertainment it's in
the way of our fill in the blank so
we're not just skipping it we're telling
ourselves a story that is optional and
then we can come up with other things to
do instead and it's not
sleep and lack of sleep affects
everything cardiovascular reproductive
metabolic systems our immunity emotional
mental health our attention span
everything
everything is affected by sleep dr
walker says that every single human
function is improved or enhanced with
sleep let me say that again
every
single human function
is improved with sleep
and every single known psychiatric
disorder involves impaired sleep
long story short the less a person
sleeps the more likely they are to die
sooner and painfully
so take a quick honest inventory of your
sleep how long do you sleep each night
and probably subtract an hour from that
because if you like lay down at nine
and you read or toss and turn or talk or
whatever then it's 9 30ish before you're
actually starting to fade and it's about
9
35 ish to 9 50ish to 10 o'clock-ish
depending on what your sleep latency is
until you're actually asleep and then
you go to the bathroom you get up all
these things you don't even know it's
like so
take an honest inventory of your sleep
how long do you sleep each night do you
turn off screens an hour or two before
bed you treat sleep like it's optional
or you treat sleep like the core
life-giving function that it is
being well
you have to rewrite these stories things
like sleep are optional that food can be
what like we have to redo those stories
you have to rewrite them
and flip these things over so that we
can live well in whole lives and again i
talk about these stories
in my new book own your past change your
future
if you pre-order today you'll get
so many bonus items including as we've
we've continued to talk i'm so grateful
for my friends at betterhelp.com had
some time to hang out with him in los
angeles they are extraordinary um who
are giving away a free
month of therapy for people who
pre-order the book go to
johndaloni.com today
pre-order the book get it get it get us
20 bucks man and it can change
everything as we wrap up today's show
we're gonna just
right on the nose guys but this is this
is literally one of my top 10 albums of
all time
off
the license to ill record
i remember i got in trouble my parents
found this tape under my bed or
something and my dad was like licensed
to kill and i was like no dad it's
licensed to ill i remember him being
like
i don't know what that means but he
didn't say it because he was a dad in
the 80s and he just looked at me
does not compute
gotcha dad license to ill record the
beastie boys and they're classic no
sleep till brooklyn and it goes like
this
no
sleep
till brooklyn
it's kind of an on the nose intro there
foot on the pedal never ever false metal
engine running hotter than a boiling
kettle my job my jobs ain't a job it's a
damn good time in city to city i'm
running my rhymes on location
current touring around the nation
beastie boys always on vacation itchy
trigger finger but a stable turntable i
do what i do best because i'm illing and
able
ain't no faking your money i'm taking
going coast to coach
no sleep till brooklyn we'll see you
later
coming up on the next episode so i
recently got diagnosed with ocd welcome
to the club welcome to the gang it's so
fun isn't it it's been a good time isn't
it though hey most people just do things
once we get to do them a bunch of times
and it doesn't make us feel any better
[Laughter]
my girlfriend has
a lot of guy friends it sounds like
you're going to be miserable i don't
think i'm miserable really i just yeah
but it makes you jealous and you wonder
what's going on and you wonder why not
you
and you yeah yeah yeah that's misery
that's